I don't want anyone from the left to be
banned ready and that's it's for that
same reason that I don't want Twitter
Facebook YouTube Google I don't want
them determining which content is or is
not deemed acceptable question of the
day we're going to get into this a
little do you think that Twitter banning
all political ads is a good thing for
our democracy or not let me ask this do
you think that the action favors one
side more than the other I'm genuinely
curious I'm gonna make my case here for
those who don't know Twitter announced
last week it would be banning all of the
political ads leading up to the 2020
election we have a clip of dead Johnny
Mathis Jack Dorsey announcing today that
Twitter will no longer accept political
ads in advance of the 2020 election
Dorsey tweeting this we've made the
decision on Twitter globally we believe
political it's all the yeses rich should
be I think it's just good between watt
forms to say we have to be the referees
somebody's got to do it and if there's
no referees and it's just complete wild
with us and we have Russians and others
they can't control the platforms good
answer no it's not answer mister mister
plaid pattern Paisley Paisley with plaid
but it's like it doesn't make sense what
is that is that the caller on his jacket
did he wear an ascot that's so many and
why is he wearing a plaid shirt button
always top without a tie that's too much
he's a cowboy you should have put all
the way and put okay should have put a
bolo tie in there by the way do you
notice that people who claim that we
need to regulate ads for fake news they
were talking about the in the same
breath they push the Russian conspiracy
theory yes come on it's like saying I
think we really need to strengthen our
laws regarding a tax evasion naturally
not including my accounts in the Cayman
Islands I think we need it for other
people and by the was it relates to
Twitter I don't know if you guys have
it's obvious they're taking the stand
because in the social media arms race
they are dead last right there behind
Facebook they're behind Instagram and
you can argue and you can argue inferred
those on the Left argue that Facebook
and allowing political ads they're just
they're just protecting their bottom
line and Twitter just says we have no
bottom line
somebody buy us please on the market
there a couple of issues that I have
here that no one else has really been
talking about you pay in political ads
okay so but Donald Trump can't run an ad
Bernie Sanders can't internet okay
that's one thing but they claim that
this is because they want they want
organic reach to be earned not bought
here's my question can ABC NBC CBS CNN
MSNBC CNBC BBC can they run ads even if
Fox News is allowed it's still an
unbelievable advantage for the left yeah
and what constitutes a political ad
still isn't really clear so that's one
thing this this is a brilliant ploy
right now they go no one can run
political ads but hold on a second right
if all networks if if the New York Times
can run an ad if Washington Post can run
a mad if Snopes can run an ad
fact-checking the president because I
have a photo shop with a dog getting the
Medal of Honor and if they can run that
as an ad because they're not technically
a political entity this is these are
questions that we need answered yeah and
what when asked for a clarification
actually think was that Jack's lawyer
was it Vijay GAD the one who was on Joe
Rogan with Tim Poole yeah they said the
criteria for leaving labeling at
political political issue ads so here I
have the actual the quote ads that refer
to an election or a candidate or ads
that advocate for or against legislative
issues of national importance such as
climate change health care immigration
national security taxes so given that
news outlets they haven't actually had
their ads labeled issue ads under the
existing guidelines it seems pretty
clear they can to continue to run these
ads as long as they just claim that
they're objectively covering stories and
for those who read out the objectively
covering the news see the people up
there who say we need people to ensure
objectivity let's talk about Russia well
here's the thing they would they want to
act as though there's some kind of a
balance of power and they go because
Donald Trump's in the White House well
hold on a second Donald Trump's in the
White House but the entire media the
entire entertainment industry every band
that you can think of every celebrity
that you can think of safe for like
Scott Baio right they're all on the far
left and they're allowed to run ads and
this is something it's important what
about let's get that individuals again
Jack Dorsey his justification for the
banning of political ads was that reach
should be earned not bought they've made
it extremely difficult for conservatives
to earn reach but the shadow' banning
the blacklisting even to
outright banning their shadow banning
and then there's ban banning so how many
other conservatives are banned from
running ads Prager University has been
banned from advertising on Twitter easy
this is something people doing at the
pro-life organization live action you
may know they were banned from running
ads on Twitter well of course Planned
Parenthood still advertisers freely easy
yeah wouldn't helmet if there are any
federal taxpayer dollars have been spent
on Twitter ads for Planned Parenthood
that abortions mind you Joe click like
if you hate Trump yeah Donald Trump is a
fascist agree and then you have you know
the Republicans Facebook people's fronts
like Hillary should be locked up do you
agree fifty five million likes oh my god
and then we kill ourselves don't do that
why we put all this work like people
know about live action one of the
requirements Twitter gave for live
action to be able to advertise it all
was they had to delete all of their
ultrasound pictures not just from ads on
Twitter but it wasn't this Twitter ad
has an ultrasound picture and I'm not
talking about chopped up baby parts it's
an ultrasound you would think okay that
seems like it should be acceptable what
they can remove it from their ads on
Twitter I don't know
live action had to remove it not only
from the Twitter ads not from their
Twitter account but from the entire
website if they wanted to run any ads on
Twitter people understand if you play
ball with it there's no guarantee that
if live action makes these changes they
would reinstate and yet this is what's
important this is what we've talked
about our fight with YouTube is just
about transparency understanding the
guidelines and making sure that they are
applied equally right if Planned
Parenthood can run ads but live action
cannot run ads unless they remove all
ultrasound pictures from even their
personal website off of Twitter then
there should be some kind of a guarantee
at that point right okay if we do that
that's not what happens so I've been
permanently banned right from
advertising on Twitter as well you
should
even though just like YouTube my ad
campaigns were created by Twitter
themselves declared them a violation of
policy so we created a bunch of
different ad sets and one of them said
hate hippies please follow me to quell
the pain and have different sets Twitter
a Twitter ad executive created it for me
was like let's try hate hippies let's
try can't stand sjw's let's try can't
sit
this is the violation so guess what I
did I took down that tweet but
apparently my entire account is in
violation because at one point I asked
if you hate hippies which you don't need
to answer that in the comments section I
know you do
bipartisan and then we like you too
let's rhetoric remember you tube basin
is this general outline like what would
you see can't you spot the [ __ ] you
need to remove the socialism shirt from
YouTube we removed what forty videos
from you to us forty videos from YouTube
and we removed the socialism is for FIGS
shirt from our website yeah we removed
any video and then some oh we have yet
to be Ramana ties just so you know so
again this is the problem this is well
if you do XY and Z will let you will let
you sit up the cool kids table and then
invariably you don't get any contact
back well Planned Parenthood runs ads as
often as they want by the way get the
notification bell if you're subscribed
because subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot
you still get notifications I guess on
your phone but those don't just check in
every day we have a new every single day
at 8:00 p.m. Eastern right quarterback
yes
ap eight penis against conservatives we
should also note the idea that you you
need to earn not buy right this sounds
noble I understand that but this also is
something for people to to understand
that's biased against anti-establishment
candidates as we saw with Tulsi Gabbard
politicians who've been around for a
very long time who've been a part of the
establishment to use up they don't need
to earn reach to the same degree yeah
but they don't eat they don't need to
buy or each I should say they already
have it by being a part of the
establishment Newark candidates who want
to challenge establishment Kennedy's are
now at a distinct disadvantage it's the
same reason that Bank of America doesn't
need to advertise their crappy services
because you already know they're on
every single corner as opposed to say
the local and on a local Chemical Bank
that's not just a bank somewhere else
it's a Midwest right
they don't have the huge market share so
they have to be competitive and they
have to have a system that allows them
to let you know why they are competitive
because they don't have that huge just
that mammoth market [ __ ] like Bank of
America has the same reason the
mom-and-pop diner would probably get
more use out of advertising locally than
a McDonald's they don't have the same
brand recognition so this is another way
for Twitter left us you should be upset
about this to Democrats to stack the
deck in favor of the establishment
candidate yeah exactly I want to go to
the city
United parallels because I'm amazed that
you don't really hear people talking
about the Citizens United feel who don't
know you've heard this if you listen to
The Young Turks or you listen to any of
the leftist news sources they talk about
it as though it was the beginning of the
downfall of our democracy citizens
united because that effectively created
super PACs okay
for people who don't know done a whole
video on this citizens united was an
issue because Hillary Clinton right this
court case it goes but Hillary Clinton
didn't want a documentary getting out
there was critical ever around a light
on time the court ruled that the
documentary could get out and that in
turn ruled that corporations consist of
people therefore they're protected under
the First Amendment as people love this
lost their mind they swear up and down
that corporations are not people okay
alright let's go with that what about
the media entities today many people are
they corporations are they allowed to
run ads now that could affect politics
or not if you're going to be upset about
citizens united because independent
filmmakers might have done some damage
to Hillary Clinton by the way if
citizens united Jeffrey Epstein would
still be alive no no no that's a good
thing there's still not this is also the
inconsistency that really bothers me
those on the Left a lot of people on the
Left I should say some of them want
political ads to stay right provided
that they're being handled I think the
exact word we have is in the Clinton
monitored the right we know what that
means I hear you I would much rather
have political ads on these platforms if
they were done correctly if they were
monitored correctly but here's the thing
I just don't trust them to do the job
correctly
I just don't completely different
political parties and I'm not just
talking about policies or ideology I'm
just talking about character right so
right you have people who will stop at
nothing to smear the other side to lie
about the other side to put out pure
propaganda well your whole channel is
that opponent just so they can get the
upper hand and they can win whereas
Democrats you know they're known for
playing patty-cakes as Jake would say so
they don't play as dirty right yeah
anyway hundred like a false impeachment
trials or smearing a man of
anger rape to avoid a Supreme Court
nominee oh I know the story came out
today where one was like I made that no
kidding oh my god Monte's gordon water
provided that it's being monitored
what point I know people throw it up
like at what point is the word Orwellian
become appropriate yes we want to give
this power to the biggest companies the
world has ever known
Twitter Facebook YouTube big tech
provided that they're monitoring it
properly this is not this is no longer
we talk about freedom of speech right we
talk about some people say well it's a
private business issue they have known
it there's no necessity for the social
media companies to allow any speech in
their platform no but right now you're
effectively calling for them to get in
bed with big government to make sure
that political ads are monitored by your
precious Jack Dorsey to make sure that
the underhanded Republicans obviously
are the ones who can run ads this is MA
this is absolutely insane to me you know
this other thing is there is this thing
as long as the right people are doing
the censoring they're ok with it and
let's look at let's look at a difference
between like the recent LGBTQ court case
against you 250 women following they're
suing YouTube for censoring of content
okay so I believe in the whatever it is
the brief that they filed half-asian
Larry bill Richmond is not here so I
might be getting my legalese incorrect
now but whatever it was that they filed
their initial petition or their initial
brief they were saying okay YouTube we
want this is what we're demanding that
you in no way you know way monitor and
no way affect our organic reach or or
algorithmic reg search traffic case so
if you absolutely want 100% transparency
also we want you to make sure that's a
safe space for LGBTQ creators by banning
people we disagree with almost Hannah
does we know who's answering content
except for all of these people except
for not me this is this is what's
remarkable to me do you do you not
understand do people not see how this
could do you not see how because this
could bite you in the ass left us here's
something let me think about this for a
second I've talked about this if you go
back and watch the am show I don't want
anyone from the left to be banned ready
and that's it's for that same reason
that I don't want Twitter Facebook
YouTube Google I don't want them
determining which content is or is not
deemed acceptable and I just talk about
on their platforms they're also
determining what's appropriate out
of their platform as with us we can't
sell a shirt that you guys wanted to buy
at ladders credit that tell me
everything else they're Atletico
shop.com but we can't have a socials mr.
Frick sure it's fine
live action can't have ultrasound
pictures on the website if they want to
be on these social media platforms let's
say the roles were reversed here I don't
know let's say that conservatives had a
president in the White House and they
had the power to ask that the president
petition you know petition the president
to ask that he censor content we
disagree with yeah we could do it we
don't know that for a second right no
one here is asking President Donald
Trump to try and silence voices of
dissent even though right now the man
the person in the highest office in the
land of course would be sympathetic to
our points of view I would be absolutely
ashamed to call president from my
president if he decided he was going to
arbitrarily determine that Democrats
wouldn't have a voice on social media
yeah we don't believe in this we believe
in consistency and transparency for all
it is remarkable to me and I also think
it's very telling if you see consider if
you see two different sides out there
and we say all sides are the same but
all Republicans all conservatives are
out there saying this is a real problem
with social media determining who's
allowed to speak and who's not allowed
to speak and then you have the biggest
voices on the left saying well it's not
a problem unless we ensure that they're
monitoring it properly so we want them
doing this but we want to have a final
saying he's allowed and who's not
allowed by the way these are the same
people the SPLC who determines what
content is hate speech what content is
allowed I don't know what hate speech is
anymore I'm not entirely sure if this
whole show could be banned as hate
speech I don't want anyone banned for
hate speech even if your content is
offensively bad just on an intellectual
and an entertainment basis I want it for
all to see
you know the drill just click one of
these other videos in a box playing up
here and I mean by there's an actual box
I don't of course mean that in the
feminine it's a slur but that of course
I don't mean box because men can have
boxes too and I don't mean to say box I
just that men can there's like a DC
outlet an AC outlet and they can be
either one that they choose depending on
electrical current or that Sarge of ions
I think